outrage over new co-ed restrictions as
millions of americans they're gearing up
for thanksgiving and protesters even
taking to the streets in california
to find a curfew there los angeles
county announcing it will suspend
in-person dining and then in nevada the
governor is issuing a statewide pause
for at least three weeks with a stronger
mass mandate and more restrictions
in nashville officials are limiting
gatherings to just eight people
an oregon's governor telling people to
call the cops on their neighbors
if they violate the rules this is no
different
than what happens if there's a party
down the street and it's keeping
everyone awake
what do neighbors do they call law
enforcement
because it's too noisy but could help be
on the way the company astrazeneca
announcing its vaccine is up to 90
effective in trials and dr fauci says
all the upcoming vaccines can help crush
the pandemic
help is on the way traditionally and
historically
highly efficacious and effective
vaccines have crushed
epidemics like smallpox and polio
and measles we can do that with the
vaccines that are going to be coming
online
so great news about vaccines and great
to have at least three options and more
are on the way but before you get to
that point jesse looks like there's
going to be
more of these rules and restrictions
like i don't think you'd ever rat me out
call the cops if i had more than eight
people over i don't think you would
the price is right dana you never know
if there's a fine involved for a reward
system i might pick up the phone
um there is a silver lining to these
restrictions around thanksgiving and
that is
there's more juicy family gossip going
around
families are silently judging other
family members for how they're behaving
during the pandemic
so you have the one family that's chock
full of the 20-somethings
and these people are high-risk they're
like out at the beach they're at bars
you know they're coming in and they're
gonna get everybody sick
you don't really want them to come but
it's hard to tell them not to come
if they do come you put them at a kid's
table even though they're 26
and you if anybody does get sick you
blame that family absolutely
then there's the family that just wants
credit for coming
they will jump through all these hoops
to get there they've been quarantining
for two weeks
they've gotten extensive tests done and
they want everybody in the family to
know
that they will stop at nothing to get
there and so they want credit
you respect the fact that they're
getting tested but you kind of roll
your eyes at their theatrics then
there's the family that
is looking for an excuse not to show up
yes these are the people that don't
follow guidelines anyway
but now all of a sudden oh they have to
follow these guidelines
sure you're looking for an out fouchy
gave you an out and you're pleasantly
taking the out that's fine
you didn't want to be there in the first
place so jesse which category do you
follow oh i'm getting there
then there's the family or like the
uncle or the aunt with the comorbidities
the people that have a lot of underlying
conditions but you don't really want to
tell them to their face
they have these conditions like the ant
the chain smokes and coughs
the uncle that's obese and has a bad
ticker everybody's saying you know uncle
joe probably shouldn't come
but they don't have the courage to say
it to their face then there's the
liberal family
okay the liberal family is not going
anywhere you have to go to them
but if you go to them you can't fly you
have to drive
you have to get tested you have to get
temperature checked before you enter
you have to wear masks you have to
social distance at the table
and if you raise any objections to these
preconditions you are judged as a super
spreader
okay and therefore you are doing what
what do you think
well i think that you're going to be the
most responsible and a good son
and good dad and good husband and i'm
looking for an out all right
you want to watch football um degen it
is some
we were talking in the green room but
that a lot of these
rules are not laws they are the
government saying
this is what we want you to do but
there's no like law behind it
no and the decisions are arbitrary and
draconian
and made by politicians who are plagued
with arrogance-induced idiocy
here's my favorite i'm just going to
open my phone and look at it this is
recently
this is on wednesday restaurants and
bars are ordered in the state of
pennsylvania that they can't sell
alcohol
after 5 p.m until 8 a.m on thanksgiving
day
why is that okay where you're gonna
crowd people you people are gonna stock
up at the liquor stores and then crowd
into people's homes
there is no rhyme or reason and all of
the restaurant owners and bar owners are
waking up to the fact that these
politicians have
zero idea what they're doing and they
make it worse because they're so
condescending and sanctimonious about
those very decisions
out in los angeles where they're
shutting in la county
shutting down restaurants the restaurant
owners are like
wait a minute we've installed thousands
of dollars of this protective equipment
and now we can't operate at
all the american people regular folks
understand how to do a risk-reward
analysis
a cost-benefit analysis they actually
know hey these lockdowns are hurting
our livelihoods our mental health
they're increasing drug and alcohol
abuse
and the politicians can't see that the
american people getting on planes good
for you
going to see relatives people they even
hate are the ones who will bring this
economy out of this malaise
you want it you want to encourage that
behavior
not hey let's listen to what he said
i wish i could say that my daily covert
presentations were
well choreographed scripted rehearsed or
reflected
any of the talents that you advance they
didn't
they offered only one thing authentic
truth
and stability but sometimes that's
enough i'm very humble greg very humble
so i guess that makes chris cuomo the
smart cuomo i always had it reversed
first of all before i talk about cuomo
i've got to say this about
sometimes people unintentionally reveal
their their major flaws
and governor brown revealed that she has
no friends
or neighbors because no person would
ever
tell you to call the police on your
neighbors
because neighbors never do that because
you have to still live there
it's not like you can call the police on
your neighbors and say there are 17
people after thanksgiving
and then you're just going to move away
you're there the day after thanksgiving
and my god you will pay if a neighbor
did that to me you will pay in ways that
you don't even understand
there are things that i could do to your
front lawn that don't go away
and they smell so bad all right toe to
cuomo
okay just to show you that life isn't
fair uh people think that we should
always be striving for fairness
it's good but life is never fair so you
have one man that ushers in a
revolutionary moon shot in terms of a
vaccine that's never been done before
and that will be a breakthrough that you
can map all future
uh um uh uh um vaccines on
he's called evil right he's evil then
you have a man
indirectly infecting thousands of people
in restrooms killing them
he wins an emmy so one gets enmity
and another one gets an emmy and why is
that
because we are live in a society that
rewards and punishes
only words and not deeds so why did why
did
uh chris cuomo uh and andrew cuomo cuomo
whatever
win something it's about his performance
his words
not about what he actually did because
what he did
was horrible absolutely horrible
meanwhile we punished trump for what
being kind of obnoxious his words
but what does he do well he just ushered
in a brand new phase of vaccines
and change the world but those are deeds
and we don't reward deeds we only reward
words that is why there's no real
fairness in society and it makes me sick
to my stomach
we deserve an enemy this show deserves
an emmy this show is the best show on tv
and we still don't have an emmy we do
deserve an emmy don't we
you know what we're too good for emmys
we're to screw you
out here that's exactly you're exactly
right screw you exactly
right now richard there are some common
sense measures that can be taken
to try to keep businesses open where to
start uh i agree i think that you have
like i think digging is right there has
to be some i think there has to be some
equilibrium though i think we have to
understand that we are months away from
possibly getting over coronavirus so
right now in the status quo
every state has an increase in
coronavirus cases hospitalizations are
through the roof
and that means we have got to be mindful
as americans we've got to wear mass
we've got to socially distance
we've got to follow some of these
guidelines as the attorney as the
surgeon general said this morning
because it's the only way
we'll even get to a vaccine as for cuomo
i'm not sure he should have gotten an
emmy
but i think it's worth pointing out that
during his his press conferences for a
lot of americans
was the only information they were
getting on coven 19 because they weren't
getting it from the president who told
us to drink bleach or injection
or use the lights
no you're gonna have to take that back
he never said he said he said maybe you
could try bleach or maybe you could use
a light
if you're going to make an erroneous
comment at least be in the ballpark oh
what do you mean what do you mean in the
ballpark
briefing
i'm gonna pull it up in the google as
soon as we no he's talking about
future research and they were talking
about how it would be really good if
there was a way
yes you know to disinfect blah blah blah
yeah it was unfair
at that point in time in the vaccine
anytime a president is going out giving
conjecture
during a press conference that's
inappropriate especially when people are
dying was killing our elderly
i'm not denying that i'm not denying
that
i'm not denying that but he's not the
president people we need kennedy's